today we're going to be focusing on just
on this one questions this is number two
okay now would you raise your hand if
you've got the question
hands up straight okay a small number of
you thank you hands down okay
for those of you who have done that what
i'd like you to do is watch
we're going to tackle these questions
i'm going to show you two different ways
to do it so even if you got it
i'm fairly certain you didn't do the
question twice so whichever way
you did it maybe one of these methods
were different to yours or
even both of those will be different to
yours there's lots of different ways to
do these questions
so the important thing for me is not the
answer but it's how do you
think about how to get towards the
answer the method in other words
okay so i've got two methods for you
here's my first one that's the number
one and i'd love you to um
write this down write this down please
method one
is to turn a subtraction
this is subtraction right one number
take away another
turn a subtraction into an edition
i'm going to ask you to be courteous go
through this i do want lots of you to
understand
how to go about doing this question and
we can't do that if there's going to be
continued constructions
is that a reasonable expectation to have
yeah
okay let's try this again okay now
what makes this challenging in the first
place is subtraction is hard to do in
our heads right
so one of the classic strategies is to
take something that's hard
and turn it into something easier in
fact the second method i'll show you
does the same thing
hard into easy but in a different way so
here's what i'd like you to have under
this heading of method one think about
how this works if i say for instance
five take away three equals two
that's a subtraction and i can turn it
into you did this in primary school
you can turn it into an equivalent
statement that's an addition what
addition statement
would go with this one so here's the
pattern two plus three
fantastic okay so being that these two
statements
are really kind of like in the same
family as it were
right i can use that to my advantage
when having a look at
this question so i've got this takeaway
this
equals that i don't know what any of
these letters are okay so i'm going to
take a subtraction
into an addition that means we're going
to read from the bottom
up right 1998 plus this
should equal that does that make sense
just like you can see i've got the
numbers
5 3 2 2 3 5 the order changes and the
operation changes does that make sense
are you following so far so let's
rewrite it yes but
also when you do it it's descending
okay very good so you can see that's
kind of a coincidence i could have had
like five
one four that would have been that would
still be true but it wouldn't
necessarily be in descending order
let's try and take it to this question
okay so i'm going to write this
plus this equals that okay 1
9 9 8 plus
this 4 7 y 6 number whatever it is 4
7 y six
and my sum at the end will be p r five t
okay now you can immediately see this is
much easier to wrap our heads around i
mean i know we could have um
trial and errored our way through the
first question you're just trying to
guess things right
but here it's really easy for instance t
hopefully t is jumping out at you when i
rewrite it in this way
t has to be equal to
careful six plus eight is
fourteen right six plus eight is
fourteen so therefore this number down
here i need a new color
this number must be a four
do you see that right and we have four
and i should carry the one
like that's just how i do normal
addition right so it's really good
i know what t is i'm going to write that
over here i'm going to gather together t
equals four so i know one thing
now when i have a look at the next part
look this is a bit trickier i've carried
this one right so 1
plus 9 plus y it'll be equal to
something and the last digit is a 5.
so what does that mean about this y in
here yeah really
y y has to be 5. now how do we know
how do we know about this right someone
want to try this one yeah go ahead
because nine plus there's still one yeah
good
so that nine of that one right they'll
become ten so a one will carry over here
and all you've got left to make up this
five is this guy
it must be five okay so i'm going to put
it here now
this must be five and sure enough one
plus nine plus five will be
15. so there's the five that i was
expecting and i'm going to carry the one
okay so i've already got t now i know
what y is equal to
it's five have a look at this
now i'm going to go straight down one
plus nine plus seven
what is one plus nine for seven yeah
it's 17 right so i should have carry the
one and this guy down here
must be seven so i've got my second last
letter r
equals uh seven and now you can tell me
the last one right
what's p have to be i've got no other
choices yeah charlie
uh um
four four hold on i've got one and one
and four and i'm adding right oh adding
that's gonna be six yeah okay so i'm
done now i've got all my letters okay
yes i don't get any of this
actually so adding do you mean addition
no all these
letters and numbers okay so the whole
idea is that i'm just sort of standing
these
letters in place for numbers i don't
know that's all that means okay
uh questions
yeah kind of in that like all these
operations they all kind of interrelate
like adding and subtracting they're kind
of like reverse
options of each other and multiplying
and dividing also opposites
okay i'm going to show you one more way
um that way it was good it worked
but i think there's an even cleverer and
quicker way to do this
okay so i'm going to leave it as a
subtraction but
i'm going to make it an easier
subtraction
let me show you what i mean
okay remember how i said look i've got
some number sentences over here
okay i can um have equivalent number
sentences based on what i know so for
instance
if i go again 5 take away 3 equals 2
right i can change some of these numbers
and still have an equivalent statement
so for instance if i make
this number here three if i make it
smaller
if i go five take away one so i made it
smaller by two
what happens to this guy
you guys know what five takeaway one is
right if i take away one of course is
four so you can see because
this number has gotten smaller what
happened to the number on the end the
difference
it got bigger do you notice that
so if i make this one smaller by two
this will get bigger by two okay
so i'm going to take advantage of that
if i know
that this take away this equals this
this is hard because it's an
icky number to deal with i want an
easier number a simpler number
right so if i can say you can get this
down with me p
r five t whatever that is okay
take away four seven y six
if that's 1998
what's a nice round number that's close
to 1998
yeah 2 000. that's really easy right and
the zeros will make things very very
simple for me if i want to make this
number
too bigger what do i have to do to this
number
what did i do before see how i made
this too bigger so what did i do here
it had to get too smaller do you see how
it's they're compensating for one
another
right it's like you give and you take
away different parts of the equation
so if this is true like that's just what
the question says
i'm going to subtract a number
that is too smaller than this now i
don't know what y
is so it's going to be 4 7 y whatever
that is
but because that 6 is going to get too
small it should be replaced with a
4. so if i make that number 2 smaller
then the result at the end will be 2
bigger which is 2 000.
now that doesn't sound like it will make
things all that different like what's
the big deal it's still a subtraction
but watch let's write this out in proper
subtraction form right
so p r 5 t
take away
okay watch how easy this is going to be
right think about the subtraction with
me by the way you don't need your
laptops
right now none of you need your laptops
at the moment as you can see
if you're doing this subtraction t take
away four
is equal to zero do you see that t take
away four equals zero
t take away four zero so what number
does
t have to be it's got a yeah
it's gonna be four right the only number
that'll work here is if t
and four are the same number so this has
to be four
how about this next one five take away y
has to be zero again we know y is going
to be it has to be the same value right
it must be the same
and i can keep going the way through r
take away seven is zero so
r's gotta be three
our takeaway seven is zero so they have
to be the same number right
and lastly it's not exactly the same but
some number you take away four you get
two
what number you take three four one and
it's gotta be six right
which of course uh six
seven five four is the number that we
got before again
so you can see different ways to go
about it
and i don't know which method you like
better which one sort of gels with your
head
and clicks back but they both